نعود اذن الى مجلس النواب بعد خصم المقاعد
الثلاثه التي تحدثنا عنها يتكون هذا
المجلس الحالي من اغلبيه ديمقراطيه ب 200
مقعدا واقليه جمهوريه
212 متقعدا هذه الانتخابات الحاليه تشهد
تنافسنا على كل مقاعد المجلس يحتاج
الجمهوريون فقط الى سته مقاعد من اجل
الوصول الى الاغلبيه وبالتاكيد هي غايته
طبعا مع الحفاظ على ما بايديهم حتى الان
اما كل ما على الديمقراطيين ان يفعل
التالي
هو ان يحافظوا على ما يملكون الان وهي
مهمه ليست بالسهله من بين
دائره انتخابيه حصر المعركه في اقل من 40
منها هذه الدوائر التي يملك الجمهوريون
فيها الفرصه ويملكون الفرصه الانتزاع بها
من الديمقراطيين يقول بعض الخبراء ان
ساحات المعارك التي نتحدث عنها هي 37
دائره البعض الاخر يرى انها 34 دائره
نيويورك مثلا بها اربع دوائر حاسمه ولايه
كاليفورنيا فيها كذلك ثلاثه ولايات او
ثلاثه دوائر بنسلفانيا بها ايضا ثلاثه بها
ثلاثه دوائر نيفادا ايضا ثلاثه باقي
الولايات بها بين مقعد او مقعدين او لا
مقعد حاسمه على الاطلاق ايه ده هذه
الانتخابات هي استفتاء على ذلك الرجل من
هو ذلك الرجل جو بايدن رغم انه قال انها
ليست استفتاء عليه بل استفتاء على
الديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده لكن في
النهايه تبقى نتيجه الانتخابات كاشفه لراي
الامريكيين في ادارته حتى الان